hello everybody uh okay so here's the
thing about this is that you know I was
watching episode it was like winter
solstice to our part one and then the
next one was gonna be part two so I'm
like okay well got a little extra time
okay I'll just watch him back-to-back
and treat it like one episode uh but I
watched the two of them and I don't know
why they're called Part one and Part two
because there's not any more of a
connection these episodes as there is in
other episodes like the only real
connection is that you know he has to go
see master Roku in or Avatar Roku in a
in the next episode and the next episode
he does that everything else is like
every other episode so uh
so apologies this is actually two
episodes put together the Winter
Solstice
hopefully I'm saying that right part 1
in part 2 so uh I know that puts none of
you off but nevertheless that's what
what this is here um okay so I'll just
refer to as part 1 bar 2 you're part one
you got angles to this nation or this
land has been burned down by the Fire
Nation at least a good chunk of it has
and there's this black and white monster
looks a lot like the Cloverfield monster
is the first thing came to my mind when
I saw it um that's just destroying this
this town here this little neighborhood
and taking people uh I guess into the
spirit world I think that's where yeah I
think it's where it takes it it's a
touch confusing uh but we'll take a
person at time away each night take them
into the spirit world
um and the avatar comes and comes and
they oh thank god you will save a thing
right any sir shrugs and goes okay not
knowing at all what he's going to do or
what this thing is or or any of that
stuff um so all right just a quick
rundown of that episode I guess real
fast I'll just do them in order um the
the two things I really like about this
one is uh again we're seeing more the
responsibilities of what Aang is gonna
have to go through and is going through
now you know again we saw serve in the
past episode sort of the weight of him
real
izing who he is and what he has to do to
account for who he is and now we have
him going into a situation where he
literally has no idea what he's supposed
to do and what again what I like about
this character and this set up in this
show which I think you could even argue
this not just for a kid show but a lot
of shows and movies do this and drives
me nuts is that they're afraid to go
into a predicament they don't think
they're strong enough they don't think
they're good enough that's very
understandable what always happens they
run away they say no I'm not good enough
the best friend come says come on get in
there you can do it and of course just
when things are looking really bad they
come in and try to fight him off of
course they saved the day not here this
is a character who doesn't think he's
good enough or doesn't know if he's good
enough uh and they say we need you to
help us and he begrudgingly says okay in
fact if anything he knows that if he
shows that he doesn't know what he's
talking about that'll be sort of a
greater danger uh and again that really
creates a nice character it's not it's
not cowardly character and now if they
want the other rat that would have been
you know pretty human but it's something
we've seen a million times and I like
that it shows real strength in egg I
like the fact that even though he has no
idea how to fix it he's gonna try and
fix it regardless uh and that's a great
tre again it makes a great hero um the
other thing I really like about this was
we a little bit more of the of the uncle
the Mako plays and first of all this the
this character goes around at this
episode with practically no clothes and
I don't think that was necessary he he's
in this hot tub a makes for himself and
it's like these earthbenders come and
take him prisoner and it's like they
don't give him his clothes what come on
he's got to go through this whole thing
like you gotta look at his boobs the
whole time I'm like dude
so that Val it'll odd and I don't know
why I think even at the end the prince
character is like why sure
on um but regardless what I like about
that is again I like the prints I think
the prints is my favorite character I
think he's the most interesting in the
most complex um he has to he has a
choice either he can go either save his
uncle or go after the avatar
um which it is even the avatar it's the
friends on the on the flight bison but
you and I like that I like they're
actually looking for uh Aang you know
they're not just like oh we'll just wait
here and see what happens is like no
they're gonna go and try and find him I
you know again they're very active which
I like or its Katara I think I don't
know I forget to episode zero I am is
gonna be a little forgetful uh so I like
the fact that he goes after his uncle
again that shows it shows good priority
in your villain and there's a lot of
things you can like about this villain
and I again for for a kid show to create
a very honorable villain I I think
that's wonderful
um and they also build up this thing
about the spirit world
which is something new we when seen
before uh and and they build up a comet
and it's so about as bigger to be
continued as anything else but they know
they have to go the fire nation to go to
this temple or Avatar Roku will appear
and the part one part two they go to the
temple uh after going through some cool
action sequences they throw a bunch of
you know fireballs in the air and the
bison has to fly past them and
everything I will ask this what are
something I do get confused about what
are the limitations and the extents of
these powers because I'm looking at this
like remembering in the second episode
like you got the prince and the uncle
there and they you know the Bisons
getting away stop him and they both use
their firepower to shoot up this giant
fireball like miles and miles into the
air yet here Vice is about the same
height and they're using catapults now
why can't they just you know they have a
harvey now not just two of them why
could they stuff like that is a little
weird but again that's really nitpicky I
know it's fantasy
I know it's like you know it's like
wyattmoy the Rings will they use the
Eagles for everything why doesn't get
off always use that lightning power he
had before it is Carol the ring raised
blah blah blah you know what it is a
nitpick uh I just wanted to explain
later maybe it's not well it kind of is
in this episode because we find out what
the comet is comet is something I came
100 years ago and the Fire Nation okay I
don't quite understand this but the Fire
Nation somehow harnessed its power from
the passing of that comet and they
became stronger uh so again hundred
years later this comet is going to come
and if if the Lord of the Fire Nation
the princess father can actually harness
the power again it's gonna be bad news
nothing against up and the war will be
over Fire Nation will rule the earth
what are the fire nation's political
believes you know and maybe they could
run a good government right we always
assume they're just bad because they
want to hostile II take everybody over
okay that sucks but may they have good
health care we don't know um being a
dick so okay so you get this episode
where yeah and goes to this temple where
uh one the past avatars is going to show
up and tell them about this comet that's
what we find out at the end and we sort
of find this new this you know this
additional quest on top of going to the
North Pole
um and get to the temple and there's
these you know these Fire Nation
warriors now who were supposed to be
like sages looking after it but I guess
they got tired of waiting is that what
that was again it was a touch confusing
um that years the years went by the
Avatar never came and now they see the
avatar and I guess they're just so
pissed it's like no we're we're Fire
Nation now um I don't know if I saw the
avatar after a hundred years or after so
long waiting I saw say the Fire
Nation and go okay avatar I I know the
mumbo jumbo it says you're gonna save us
and everything I'm on your side so one
of them is one of them helps them out
and gets him inside the door there's a
really great seat I can't
art smart smart writing in this where
they're trying to open the door but they
need firebenders to open it and Sokka
gets this idea to put these little
explosives in that he can put together
tries them it doesn't work and they say
well wait it looks like it did work so
they hide wait for the other five to
come in they say he's inside open it up
and then when they open it baby Gemma
from behind now the reason I bring that
up is because what I thought they were
gonna do I thought this would have been
funnier but not nearly as clever is that
they try opening it up it doesn't what
you know an egg tries to open a it's not
working not working and I thought what
they were gonna do is Sokka was just
gonna say I don't get it where I thought
I was gonna lean against the door it
turns out you just had to push instead
of pole I thought they might have been a
little funny but not nearly as clever I
thought when when Katara is actually
putting together weight it looks like it
worked
that's much smarter and I'm pissed I
didn't think of that and that my ideals
I drew much stupider but it would have
been funny so but regardless um so Aang
goes in the prince comes in and on top
of that that jerky general comes in
they're all gonna try and take the
avatar I love scenes like that with just
all the characters meet up in one place
and it's just gonna amount to a big
explosion that's pretty much what
happens um in this one and what I
realized too is what I like about this
show is what I remember I liked about
lost as well is that because they're
creating this world where they can make
stuff up they can make up powers they
can make up locations they can make of
creatures they can just make it all up
ah you don't exactly know what
everything is capable of so for example
at the end Roku is talking to Aang and
Aang knows he has to get out of there
and he has no plan there's no you know
there's tons of guards out there you
know he can't stop them and the door
opens up and you see that they've
actually combined and now it's Roku with
all his powers beating the out of
everybody now this could have been
common knowledge who knows but in this
world we didn't
know that when the door opens up and you
see him there that's a great holy-shit
moment and it's great seeing them you
know wipe the floor with everybody in
the big explosion a tower falling in the
lava and the Bison coming it's wonderful
so I realize that's one of the big
advantages about how much control you
have over a world is how much you also
reveal and lost knew just how much to
reveal until the end but that's
something else um and I feel this show
does - it really knows just how much to
reveal about a world and just how much
to show and how much to keep quiet and
how much to Saurus save and let it come
later um and and I'm trying to think I
think the only other thing I can really
think about these two episodes that this
one in particular the part - what was
especially good the ending of part one I
thought was a little like it's good but
I honestly oh it's just a sample forest
creature got lucky corns and that he
lets all the people go we're even kind
of were they you know have you they were
in the spirit world they never talk
about what's like to be in the spirit
world or it was a panda - I was a fan
maybe you'll be explained again I I
shouldn't jump to conclusion as a show
does you know pick up a lot of this
stuff but I thought maybe the ending up
that a little stronger but what 24
minutes of even bad you got it yeah
squeezin a lot so I totally get it
um but the ending of this one of part
two uh I really like you felt like a lot
happened in that one episode I was
accomplished you have sort of this new
information that's very threatening and
it's almost like a new quest but you
still have the old question going on as
well what I like is that with this
intake of all this information now
there's this even greater responsibility
and this inability to get the sources
you need you can't he knows he's not
gonna have time to do whatever you learn
the firebending in the waterbending is a
he's knocking time the end of the summer
uh he has to stop this what I really
like is that as they're flying off into
the moon set whatever it is that they're
flying off into the moon all that
information is laid on you he hasn't
told Sokka or Katara and they're flying
off and totally silent they just go they
sort of put their hands on Aang it's a
far away shot they serve going into the
moon and there's just no dialogue
that's great that's something again you
don't even see an adult shows that much
they usually they have to sort of sum up
either what they've realized or what the
next episode is going to be uh and they
don't do that here and there's not even
really a cliffhanger it's like it's just
letting the information kind of sit with
you and from a distance as well I would
have been so easy just to go for a
close-up on Aang or seeing the brother
and sister looking concerned and it's
all from far away I thought that was
really cool I actually even were wounded
just to say like did they say anything
did they reveal anything else at the end
or restate what their new mission is and
they didn't uh I thought a very mature
choice I thought that was a very cool
thing to do um and yeah I just really
ate that up so uh again two great
episodes don't know why it was part one
in part two but there you go and just
adding more and more stuff and keeping
the right amount of stuff hidden until
it's revealed hopefully you'll be a bear
revealed and lost um but again just
having a great time with it and I can't
wait to see the next one